first we go back to the crisis on our
southern border DHS secretary Chris
Kirsten Nielsen released a statement
yesterday saying the migrant caravan is
quote far larger more organized than
previous ones earlier I sat down with
the Secretary to talk about this and so
much more
Madam Secretary good to see you let's
talk first about about the weekend
let me quote one water patrol chief
Karla Provost our agents were being
assaulted a large group rushed the area
throwing rocks and bottles at mine men
and women putting them in harm's way and
numerous other similar reports how bad
was it
well you know it shot first follow me to
say this is a testament to the training
and professionalism of the Border Patrol
that no one was hurt we had a thousand
people rushing the border in a very
violent and lawless way we will not
stand by as our Border Patrol are
attacked so they defended themselves
yeah well I don't I don't know if they
have any choice the thing is we we see
now that the mayor interestingly if
Tijuana said excuse me Trump was right
this is an invasion and they have now
had a lot of issues that they've had to
deal with but the migrants the caravan
are still coming and they're coming in
bigger numbers
what if larger numbers of people rushed
the border are you even for that you're
prepared we were prepared this time we
will be prepared for any additional
migrants the the president has made it
quite clear we will not tolerate illegal
or violent entry into our country so
this time he talked about it for a month
in advance as the kervins were making
their way up he raised awareness he
called in the military he called in
Constantino wire we hardened the ports
we called an additional law enforcement
state and local and federal and we were
prepared we will be prepared we will not
allow illegal entry into our country one
one thing the president said why if
they're going to be seeking asylum
they're going to not be in this country
or allowed in this country while
whatever process goes forward one of the
problems have been people cross the
border they claim asylum they get a
court date they're released into America
and they never
up again so is how how insistent is the
president that they stay in Mexico and
how our relations with Mexico
considering they were told a long time
ago they should be dealing with this
yeah you know this is an important point
that you raised Sean ultimately we only
see about nine percent ten percent of
Central Americans who make an asylum
claim actually be granted asylum by an
immigration judge and that's that's
really important that's really important
to put in perspective so 90 percent of
those making asylum claims are not
making a claim that can be honored under
the statutory framework within the
United States it's not a valid reason
for asylum you've heard me say it before
if you're coming to get a job that's not
a claim for asylum if you're coming to
be with your family that's not a claim
for asylum is it likely they're going to
be coached and if they really want to
did in Mexico offer them work permits to
work in South Mexico and that was
apparently rejected by most and how many
people are we now talking about in the
remaining Caravan still making its way
north so we believe there will be about
10,000 ultimately there's between eight
and ten thousand now but you're exactly
right the government of Mexico offered
everyone asylum they also offered work
permits that's why this Caravan is very
different than ones we've seen in the
past not only is it violent but to the
extent that it claims that its members
would like to seek asylum they've been
offered asylum but they've turned it
down in Mexico let me play a SOT from 60
minutes this was Scott Pelley and the
argument is about the separation issues
and how there was a warrant for one
three year olds and I want to get your
response to it the president tweeted out
and we have images of even young people
when Obama was president that are behind
fences they would say it's cages if it
was Donald Trump but what's inside the
Trump administration made the decision
to separate children from families what
responsibilities did they take on in
your estimation they issued an order
without consulting with the agencies who
were responsible for carrying out that
order we take better care of people's
effects when we send them to jail then
we
care of the children who we took from
their parents you quit your job at
Homeland Security I wonder why I had
taken an oath to uphold the Constitution
we were being asked as a department to
do something that violated the civil
rights and civil liberties of persons
I want to get a reaction that and wasn't
it President Trump that stopped the
practice through an executive order
Shawn it was but I you know I am so
disappointed in that piece that that is
journalism that's not journalism that's
factually incorrect we did not have a
policy to separate families from
children what the president said what
all presidents have said before him as
we went first the law this president
takes out very seriously so what you saw
was as we enforce the law against those
who chose to enter illegally mind you
not go legally to a port of entry but
enter illegally
they were prosecuted and because of that
if they had children with them so as not
to put children in a custodial jail they
were separated and put into good care of
HHS I yeah 60 minutes they need to go
back and check their facts and they
should have taken more time to
understand how the immigration laws of
this country work